o
[Música]
oi todo mundo para quem não me conhece
eu me chamo Paloma Costa
mas acho que antes de tudo importante
dizer que eu sou nascido aqui nessa
terra Brasil da geração Brasília filha
de minha mãe
mulher feminino e bom saindo aí pelas
coisas mais práticas
sobre acharam direito e também estou
estudantes de Antropologia dos seres
tentando um pouquinho entender tudo isso
só ativista
ciclista Educadora
defensora sós e tal
mobilizadoras mundo sei lá trabalhando
isso há seis anos
só articuladora Nacional da Inveja mundo
foi uma das criadoras do movimento the
best futuro são pesquisadora no
escritório e jurídicos pela diversidade
étnica e cultural que a clínicas
Direitos Humanos da UnB são uma das
impulsionadores do movimento frases para
o fio tchau Brasil
sou também parte da coalizão feminista
por ação climática da ONU mulheres
soma das super 31 das super sete jovens
que foi escolhida no mundo para
assessorar o secretário geral da ONU em
clima há
alguém que sabe um pouquinho da hora que
fala do que fala eu acho
mas na verdade
um resultado de um trabalho que foi tão
coletivo e que Deus bando de títulos na
verdade não significa muito o que
significa
at
todo esse trabalho coletivo deu a mim
essa possibilidade da credibilidade para
projetos ideias sonhos e iniciativas
destas tanta Juventude de inversa que
estão aí no front na base e bom é essa
ser é coisa que impulsiona a mente que a
gente vai tentando fazer
e mas aí a gente se pergunta será que
tudo isso é suficiente será que toda a
estação essa dedicação essa ansiedade
essas horas de perdas e Juventude a
todos qualquer coisa é suficiente que
seria suficiente
eu venho aqui falar com vocês é na
acabado de voltar da Tec op que
aconteceu em Milão é talha e da copa foi
mais um mês e meio intenso simplesmente
dialogando articulando agenda do clima
com diferentes e tomadores de decisão
atores juventudes tanto no Brasil quanto
no mundo bom mês e meio que a gente tá
aí direto trabalhando na própria para
cópia pela cop mas esse trabalho é um
trabalho que começa muito antes muito
antes da gente da maior parte das
pessoas nesse mundo sabe o que é clima
é bom jumento que vem antes de mim e que
seguiram depois de mim
é mas aí a gente foi lá presta cop que
foi uma das cópias talvez que tinha essa
expectativa que seria copo mais
importante de toda a história da
humanidade era uma copa que acontecer
depois da pandemia E nós como juventudes
a gente sabe o qual a importante essa é
a nossa voz lá trazendo e talvez desse
pouquinho já são de ambição e não foi à
toa que a gente levou a maior delegação
de juventudes já registrada na história
de conferências da ONU para uma cop é O
que foi a maior delegação de jovens
brasileiras imagens de jovens
latino-americanos só no Brasil nós
éramos mais de 70 jovens de diferentes
partes
territórios periferias comunidades Norte
sul leste oeste do Brasil de tudo que
estava todo mundo lá não todo mundo mas
muita gente
e bom
tá vamos lá
respostas da trazer a nossa realidade a
compartilhar os nossos sonhos
iniciativas e projetos e articular toda
essa mudança que a gente tem feito no
front daqui Se pudesse acontecer e
continuar e é coar e o espaço como a
foto
é mas por mais que a gente tivesse lá
ainda faltava espaço ainda faltava de
fala que encarar essa juventude que tem
feito de tantas são as diferentes partes
do mundo como verdadeiros
os tomadores de decisão a ser
compartilhado em todos os processos
difícil com verdadeiras parte
das decisões tratam da gente do nosso
presente e do nosso futuro Nada mais
justo do que perguntar que a gente
também deveria estar lá né e a gente tá
gestão no entanto espaços
Tá bom
mas tá valendo tudo isso
e o que deixa mais frustrante é que uma
Copi como essa
e
depois ge uma pandemia depois de um
relatório do ipcc ser que mostra para
gente que a gente tem menos dez anos do
que a gente imaginava para alcançar um
lugar o e-mail que foi aquele acordo que
a gente fez lá no pares
tô falando que o planeta todo ia medir
todos os esforços para que a gente não
chegasse aí aparentemente para acontecer
ainda nesta década se a gente sobreviver
que a gente que sabe que vem aqui da
América do Sul vai ser o lugar mais
impactado pela crise do clima e depois
da gente teve vídeo diversas queimadas
queimando a nossa vida diante dos nossos
olhos uma crise massiva de perda de
biodiversidade
ameaças a sós ambientalistas lideranças
indígenas ribeirinhas quilombolas no
front vendo todas as a boiada de um
projeto de morte planificado passar
e se fã dúvidas Floresta água tudo tudo
que a e com mais e mais novas pandemias
chegando e crises uma emergência do
clima
uma crise ecossistêmica e um colapso
estrutural
o que levaram a gente entender que mais
profundos que um vazio de estruturas em
sustentáveis que a gente um dia acredito
que não sustentavam é esse vazio de
Promessas de responsabilidades de dar
possibilidade a um futuro
estojos para nós
nativos de lugares que vão desaparecer
já chegou cor assunto raiva a vida se
vai esse não resultado da coppe foi
registrado nas lágrimas do presidente da
Copa 26 alok sharma durante seu discurso
final
mostra para gente um futuro de
inexistência
e assim não resultado da coppe pode
também ser registrado na nossa história
de humanidade com um discurso
pronunciado também estamos
secretário-geral da ONU se desculpando e
pedindo para gente não desistir nós
juventudes lideranças indígenas
lideranças mulheres falando que a gente
não pode se abalar com o resultado tão
ruim quanto esse uma falta de ação uma
falta de promessa uma falta de
responsabilidade
Oi e aí
acabando com uma possibilidade de
qualquer futuro de qualquer resistência
a gente pergunta né a gente acerta o que
imunes é saindo ação como sendo talvez a
melhor vacina
esses acordos da floresta que não
internacional parece ser a grande
solução para tudo mas que quando chegam
aqui querendo fazer a boiada passar
flexibilizando o licenciamento ambiental
liberando mineração em territórios
indígenas
e no momento que nem se aplica fundo
clima fundo Amazônia para acabar com
esse chamado desmatamento legal que dia
legal
é nada só mata
eu vou acreditar nessa falsa promessa
ainda de uma coisa de parede que não
começa a ser cumprido a gente canal
ansiedade climática existe
eu não quero viver num mundo de se diz
que ninguém quer viver num mundo desses
e a balança da Justiça já tá pesando
totalmente para um lado para uma direção
e já tá ceifada nossa história nossa
cultura nossa vida e a gente faz o que
aceita
fica de braços cruzados espera o mundo
acabar o colapso de tudo de todos
E aí eu me lembro
e já daquele sentimento
e quando a gente estava na marcha
reunido milhares e milhares de pessoas
lá lá em Glasgow na Itália lá em
katowice na Polônia lá em Madri na
Espanha aqui no Brasil no Chile
na Argentina na Colômbia nos Estados
Unidos todo mundo todo tava na rua
marchando no mesmo time dele no mesmo
tom ao mesmo passo é o mesmo som
querendo uma coisa zonas momento que
tivessem um pouquinho do que se chama
Justiça climática uma teoria Talvez um
conceito que não é definido mas que a
gente sabe muito bem o que significa e
não importa qualquer teoria para a gente
saber o que que significa na prática
significa o por exemplo a gente não tem
que estar preocupado com os nossos
amigos com a nossa vida com tudo sendo
ameaçado de morte com a nossa estrutura
nossa vida toda cifrada diante de nós e
aí eu E aí quando tava na Amazônia
quando havia no nome e ele deu para a
juventude o ar que ele havia recebido
Direct grande Cacique a unir falando só
que é para a juventude continuar essa
luta que a gente começou há tempos atrás
pelos nossos territórios pelos direitos
dos povos indígenas agora cabe a vocês
continuar essa luta de quando Marina
passa para gente também o batom de
quando lá atrás foi criado Essa aliança
dos povos da floresta e que quando ela
trabalhava com o ministra colocou o
Brasil no front de liderar essa disputa
pelo clima a gente tá aí trazendo
ambição trazendo Mudança Já lembrar de
tu ir a Chico Mendes de todos nós
marielles que nos levantamos nós somos
nossas para defender Talvez uma coisa
mais importante que a gente tenha esse
vai costuma coletivo do qual nós somos
parte faz e també que depende de nós e
que nós pretendemos dele
Oi e aí me veio a lembrança do que me
ensinou saiba xakriabá de que os limites
dessa terra eles estão na nossa
consciência
e se tomar nossa consciência a gente
precisa retomar é aterrar a nossa vida
ela não tá a venda a gente já trabalhou
muito para entender essa teoria de
direitos são humanos para deixar coisas
tão simples
como
morte destruição passar
e a gente bem sabe que se a gente quiser
vim para conter essa queda do céu cada
um que vem somar para segurar ele
sabendo que a gente precisa de todos
para continuar sobrevivendo nesse
planeta por nós para nós gente pensava
que quanto mais quanto mais um o que faz
que esse céu continue aí na sobre as
nossas cabeças
Oi e aí a gente até viu o coração voltar
a pulsar
Lembrando que nós não somos líderes que
o futuro que na verdade nós somos
líderes do agora ele que esse presente
assim uma máquina de fazer futuros e que
se a gente fica e sucumbe essa inação
a gente não vai chegar a lugar nenhum a
gente já saiu para onde dessa maneira
e não dá para ficar esperando amanhã ser
útil na verdade a verdade na verdade é
que a gente não pode ficar esperando
nada mais é
e a gente tem que tomar as rédeas na
nossa história acabado
complementar todos esses gargalos de
crises estruturais colapso
socioambientais
perda de direitos e realmente
lembrar da simplicidade que nos ensinou
Emicida Agora durante a pandemia que
tudo que nós tenha nós e se a gente não
quiser a gente fala articular a nossa
própria extinção
eu não sei talvez o que a gente devo
fazer agora é acreditar e começar por
cada um de nós e não nesse sentido
individualista porque se eu puder
compartilhar que um pouquinho não
acredito muito que a que a mudança
necessária Ela vem porque cada um faz da
e ações individuais achando que boy só o
suficiente
não nada disso
se vende ações coletivas
quanto mais e mais que somam mais um
mais um e mais um a gente consegue
garantir o necessário para
continuar sobreviver existir e aí eu
sonho dessa Pátria grande Ogre pala sem
fronteiras em que
em todas as bençãos que vem a gente sabe
repartir de igual entre nós
reflorestando
consciências
mentes corações
eu sei lá é aterrando a nossa ação a
nossa existência nesta terra
Talvez seja esse o suficiente um grande
educar no clima que no saque adiante
comum
comunidade Global
Master aqui tudo suficiente
Será que seria tudo isso suficiente para
garantir a nossa existência Nossa
continuidade nesse planeta nessas terras
Eu acho que o suficiente para a gente
sobreviver a gente sente sobre a gente
encontra tudo aqui
é mas
acho que nesse momento que a balança
pesa para um lado mais que um lado nem
para o outro
e talvez seja a nossa Escolha entre e
para esse dá um futuro sem notar o seu
nilo para não acabar com a queda do céu
ao eixo Z
E aí